more unpopular nutrition truths that
Wellness influencers don't want you to
know emergency is not going to cure your
cold if you're chronically skimping on
sleep a fruit smoothie may be less
satiating than the equivalent amount of
whole fruit but it doesn't mean that
it's bad eating 8 lbs of raw food a day
is not evidence of food Freedom you're
more likely to get sick from stressing
over every ingredient in your food than
you are from the food grade Kagan in a
Costco chicken suggesting fruit juice is
as bad as soda is like equating zinc
consumption with lead raw milk is not
easier on the gut than pasture
if anything it's going to do a number on
the old gut when it causes foodborn
illness which of these nutrition truths
is going to make the most Wellness
influencers mad